des violences policières qui auraient pu
passer inaperçue le soir du samedi 21
novembre
michel est clair producteur de musique
se tient devant la porte de son studio
dans le xviie arrondissement de paris
des policiers le suivent dans l'entrée
de ses locaux sur les images de
vidéosurveillance
on le voit être frappée à de multiples
reprises par les forces de l'ordre
côté rue alors que michel est interpellé
il est de nouveau violemment roué de
coups il affirme également avoir fait
l'objet d' insultes à caractère raciste
ces personnes là était censé le protéger
donc moi j'ai rien fait pour mériter ça
et je veux juste que ces trois personnes
là soient punis par la loi
j'ai eu la chance contre un mois
beaucoup d'autres d'avoir des vidéos qui
me protège parce que sinon je serais en
face de vous ou sinon je réponds en face
de vous aujourd'hui et vous serez tous
en train de faire des sujets sur moi
parce que j'aurais pris larmes de
policiers j'aurais agressé un policier
j'aurais mis des coups de poing à un
policier dans un premier temps michel
est clair et placé en garde à vue
une enquête est ouverte pour violences
sur personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique et rébellion
mais à la suite de la publication des
images par le site l'outsider l' enquête
est classée sans suite
michel éclair sera resté 48 heures en
garde à vue avant de voir enfin un
médecin le parquet de paris ouvre une
nouvelle procédure cette fois à
l'encontre des policiers pour violences
par personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique et faux en écriture publique
les images qui ont fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux ne tarde pas à faire
réagir le monde politique
gérald darmanin est invité à réagir ces
images elles sont inqualifiables
elles sont extrêmement choquantes et dès
que j'ai pris connaissance de celle ci
de ce qui s'était passé j'ai demandé la
suspension de ces policiers et dès que
les faits seront établis par la justice
puisqu'elle est saisie je demanderai la
révocation de ces policiers des on salit
l'uniforme de la république
et si encore une fois la justice
démontrent en effet ces faits qui font
peu de doute alors oui il nous devrons
plus porter cet uniforme ils seront
révoqués de la police nationale
le président de la république finit lui
aussi par s'exprimer publiquement
dans une lettre publiée sur le réseau
social facebook
ils réclament une police exemplaires et
dénonce l'agression du producteur de
musique les images que nous avons tous
vu de l'agression de michel et claire
sont inacceptables
fonte la france ne doit jamais se
résoudre à la violence ou la brutalité
d'où qu'elles viennent
la france ne doit jamais laisser
prospérer la haine ou le racisme
je croise dans la république exemplaire
une police exemplaire avec les français
des français exemplaire avec les forces
de l'ordre comme avec tous les
représentants de l'autorité publique
suspendu depuis les quatre policiers mis
en cause dans l' enquête ont été placés
en garde à vue dans les locaux de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale
une garde à vue prolongée de 24 heures
ce samedi
trois d'entre eux sont entendus pour
violences volontaires en réunion avec
arme et injures à caractère raciste
le quatrième est soupçonné d'avoir lancé
une grenade lacrymogène dans le studio
de musique pour forcer michel éclair à
sortir une affaire qui arrive en pleine
polémique sur l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale un texte qui vise à
restreindre la diffusion d'image des
forces de l'ordre